all right so let's be perfectly honest
this weekend none of you want to see me
review cats and dogs - or that Zac Efron
movie but I got to entertain you guys so
we're gonna talk about a trailer of
awesomesauce all right so I just saw a
trailer to Zack Snyder's new movie no
not the owl movie sucker punch all right
so we're looking at the character
posters the movie immediately grabbed
the attention of its target audience to
me I mean just in looking at a couple of
them you notice this movie has hot girls
medieval swords samurai swords mechs
thigh-highs castles guns dragons
whatever ridiculously hot look she's
giving Sailor Moon if she were at a rave
World War two planes leggings from
Frederick's of Hollywood more thigh
highs sephiroth's shoulder piece a girl
licking a sucker and carla Gugino just
saying yeah would you still rather be
watching that review of cats and dogs -
exactly so the premise of sucker punch
is apparently this girl or these girls
get institutionalized into the loony bin
and they regress into a world in their
own minds as a coping mechanism pendants
Sailor Moon until bill meets samurai
warriors dragons and Nazis set in 1940
fetal Japan and medieval times with
cinematography from 300 and crazy anime
with ridiculously hot girls it's pretty
much the best I can describe it or just
imagine every dream I've ever had got
thrown on a screen for your
entertainment that is probably a better
description right there so I guess
sucker punch shows what goes through the
mind of a crazy person when they get
thrown into the feed farm which is kind
of unsettling because it looks the same
as what I imagined every day hmm
so why for what I'm looking forward to
sucker punch at first sucker punch might
look like it's one of those sex sells
tactics then you watch the trailer and
you see what it really is
sex sells with more awesome badassery in
it you know you like it today I think
sucker punch will be a movie where
everyone wins because us guys will be
like hmm
and girls can be like girl power because
let's face it those outfits scream
respect me as a woman so click the link
below watch the trailer and let me know
what you think and of course if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]